two by-election defeats and the surprise
resignation of his party chairman
but it doesn't seem to faze the prime
minister despite his rather cheerful
admission yesterday that he had stuffed
up
however it may well reignite chatter
among some conservative mps about mr
johnson's leadership
joining me now is a conservative
commentator tim montgomery good morning
tim
boris johnson said yesterday that he
didn't think that there was much chance
that he'd be changing his behavior any
time soon or indeed his psychology well
you've worked for him and with him and
you know him do you agree with his
self-assessment
i'm afraid i
do think that he seems pretty committed
to carrying on as he has done for quite
a while you mentioned trevor that i
worked for him very briefly and it was
very briefly it was um just before the
2019 election and just afterwards and i
saw uh in the brief time that i was um
working for him an awful lot of
dysfunction in downing street a lack of
structure
um a lack of direction and i suggested
to him put a proposal to him that he
brought in a former
white house chief of staff or someone
who'd run the australian prime
minister's office to carry out a wide
sort of spread review
of how his downing street was run to get
ahead of the problems that i could see
coming
and he simply wasn't interested in that
sort of um reorganization i think he
he thrived on chaos in some ways as as
as a child um and he is still likes
really some sort of chaos around him
really is it allows him to rise above it
and so i'm afraid i don't really see
any great potential for a serious change
of course
so you you're basically saying
this is the nature of the beast
and i think you now regard him pretty
much as an albatross around the neck of
the conservative party um
do you think there's anything
that can be done to get that albatross
to drop i mean rather
prayer and repentance are clearly not
going to be
uh enough
in on offer here are they
i think the conservative party will get
rid of the prime minister before
the general election i was surprised by
the scale
of the rebellion in the vote of no
confidence that took place think about
two weeks ago
but the thing that surprised me more was
as i went round westminster the
westminster village around the houses of
parliament in the days afterwards
the number of tory mps who came up to me
or i had a cup of tea with who'd voted
for boris johnson in that leadership
election who were nonetheless determined
in due course uh to oust him now some of
them had supported him
because they weren't aware that there
was a they were still waiting for a
credible alternative to emerge which is
a huge question
others are fully aware you've just had a
very interesting discussion with
a union leader who is determined to
bring chaos really to britain as other
union leaders are i think a lot of tory
mp is aware that these next nine to 12
months will be difficult they don't want
the new leader to have to be in place
during that period better to get the new
leader in after then and so at some
point because of a variety of reasons
toy mps will
will get rid of him they just weren't
sure a couple of weeks ago was the right
time to do so
you mentioned there the uh obstacle in
many people's minds that there doesn't
appear to be an obvious successor um can
you see one
i can see
a number of candidates that would be
good prime ministers and i think nearly
all of the candidates can you name one
or two
uh happily i would think that um sergey
javid would bring confidence to the job
i think that deems the harwi would bring
great unity to the job i think tom
tougenhart would bring a clarity on
foreign and security policy i think all
of them
all of the main candidates would bring a
sort of sense of direction
and unity and moral sort of leadership
what they have to convince all of us is
to
give more details show that they have a
team around them because what the
conservative party can't risk is going
from
one um failed leader to one who isn't
ready and so there needs to be
mechanisms in the in the party over the
coming months to test the possible
candidates and ask some searching
questions and we all know trevor that
behind the scenes they are all
maneuvering and i think it's time that
they're a little bit public about it
but more public about it so that they
can be held accountable and we can ask
them the sort of questions that we need
to to find out if they're ready
tim thank you so much and i i hope that
between us we haven't wrecked anybody's
chances by naming them but anyway we
shall see